we're in the midst of the worst refugee
crisis since World War two as people
flee conflicts and human rights abuses
in places like Syria Afghanistan Iraq
and Eritrea so what are the world's
richer countries doing about it
compared to others not enough currently
it's the developing countries that host
most of the world's refugees and when it
comes to Syrians who make up one out of
four of all global refugees it's no
different of the 4 million Syrians who
have fled their country since 2011 3.6
million have ended up in Turkey Lebanon
and Jordan Iraq Egypt and Libya have
taken in Syrians too and even though
Europe appears to be bearing the brunt
of the crisis the entire European
continent has received only 348 thousand
Syrians but still you leaders can't
agree on what to do and the continents
complicated asylum laws aren't helping
the Dublin regulation says refugees can
only apply for asylum in the first
country that they arrived in it can't
apply from an embassy so refugees do
whatever it takes to reach the continent
for years human traffickers have preyed
on this desperation and their business
is booming refugees pay smugglers
thousands of dollars but the fee does
not guarantee their safety thousands
have drowned trying to cross the
Mediterranean hundreds more have lost
their lives trying to make the journey
on land and these laws have put a lot of
pressure on Europe so called frontline
countries over 200,000 asylum seekers
have entered Greece in 2015 alone in a
bold move Germany recently upended the
Dublin regulation by saying it's willing
to take in refugees no matter which
country they reach first Chancellor
Angela Merkel wants the rest of Europe
to follow Germany's lead papads ganses
musically you start mostly for unfolding
as we began the fruiting at Thailand
Germany says it'll accept 800,000
refugees this year
loan fueled by anti-immigrant sentiment
some countries are resistant to playing
host mean my bank isn't anything you
won't wanna host for me no thorium K
attorney not some would steam cutter
shikaka
a zombie political and what about the
nearby Gulf countries which are among
the richest in the world some of them
have played a role in the war by backing
groups fighting the Syrian government
but guess how many Syrian refugees
they've taken in altogether zero and the
Syrian government's biggest backers in
the war Russia and Iran have also taken
in no Syrians even though Iran does host
around 1 million refugees from other
countries Israel which occupies a part
of Syria has also refused to take in
refugees fleeing the war and the United
States a country with a proud history of
resettling refugees well it's given the
most aid to Syrians but guess how many
Syrians were given asylum in the US
since 2011 only around 1,500 but if the
u.s. went by IRC suggestions it should
take in 43 times that number given the
scale of human tragedy and the
desperation these refugees now face
shouldn't the world's richer countries
step up and do more